mrs. le I'm detective Barnes I'm
investigating your husband's murder and
I got some deputies out searching the
area but until we can get this figured
out
I ordered a police detail for your house
how are you feeling Anthony not everyone
cares that dad's dead
real mature gentlemen is everything okay
here
[Music]
yeah they you know Megan hi Dylan why
you being so nice to me I figured you
might need a friend was I I heard some
kids talking about your dad yeah he uh I
heard that guilt then my dad died to
suicide I was wondering if we can help
you some people over tonight of course
mom this is Dylan
[Music]
oh my god Dylan sorry I wasn't expecting
anyone I don't worry about it I mean you
have nothing to be sorry about
I always mark like mark meant well but
it didn't matter what I had to say you
know you don't always feel the way
you're supposed to but someone dies you
know what I do what he feels sad
something I'm not supposed to my god
death threats whoever hacked into her
husband's email before his death must
have had access to your an account
did you ever confess your affair to your
husband my mom had an affair there was
some real estate mogul few years ago
your real estate boyfriend you thought I
wouldn't notice I see you're not upset
dad's dead that's not true
I don't know what kind of game you're
trying to play both what are you doing
still inspiring about who is a a do it I
have him this is the knife my dad used
to slit his wrists
if you hadn't seduced into my dad
Anthony's dad would be alive and well I
killed him and now his blood is on your
hands
mom my father's death
the only person responsible is your dad
you